je suis crevée mille mercis pour hier
soir vous nous avez fait le meilleur
accueil possible le lancement n'était
pas parfait il ya eu pas mal de
problèmes vous nous avez fait énormément
de retours et derrière merci parce que
ça nous aide à avancer a évolué le
premier gros problème c'était leçon
c'était un peu la merde apparemment sur
le live le deuxième problème c'est que
ça faisait un peu trop telle est la dure
convient ressenti qu'il a besoin de voir
une émission de télé et je comprends
tout à fait parce que vu que c'était le
tout premier prime et qu'on savait
qu'elle avoir énormément de gens qui
avaient nous regarde et vous il ya eu un
pic à plus de 140000 viewer du coup on
avait une pression de malade et
effectivement c'est tous tenu un petit
peu en retrait on n'osait pas trop faire
les choses à la rage comme on adore les
fermes et vous inquiétez pas c'était la
toute première émission dans tous les
prochains problème ce sera beaucoup plus
fluide beaucoup plus d'improvisation
ce qui impliquera aussi beaucoup plus de
galère mais ces paraphes s'est accordé
au monde et sur internet et le troisième
mort aux proches vous avez fait c'était
qu'on va pas parler de la de la
programmation ni de streamer j'ai pas
présenté les streamer et je vais
présenter le programme alors que c'était
prévu mais en début de prime et c'est
complètement compte commencer le prime
avec ça enfin je trouve du coup je les
appelais mais j'aurais dû effectivement
à la fin revenir là dessus et en parler
et je suis désolé pour ceux qui
attendaient ça et qui du coup était un
peu déçu mais du coup on va faire une
émission là dans 40 minutes pour
présenter en détail les streamer et le
programme et cette émission sera en
rediffusion sur la chaîne youtube le
stream le lien dans la description
n'hésitez pas allez vous abonner comme
ça vous pourrez être au courant vraiment
de caisse qui va la voir sur le stream
et vous décidez de si vous décidez fait
parler comme ça vous allez pouvoir vous
projetez savoir si des émissions sont
susceptibles de vous intéresser ou non à
es4 et moi aussi mais ça je pense que
c'est plus les gens qui sont déjà
habitués au stream
ils voulaient plus de jeux vidéo mais le
prime c'est une mission où le principe
c'est de ne pas faire de jeux vidéo ou
très peu là pour la première on n'a fait
que la nintendo switch mais faut se dire
que c'est juste une émission d'une heure
et quelques le mercredi mais que les six
jours qui suivent il ya 1 milliards
d'émissions ou c'est du jeu vidéo
donc ne vous en faites pas pour ça vous
allez voir gotaga et mika mettre des
gros et schott et carys des games / h1n1
rover roach ya pas de souci pour ce et
5e en bas le site qui est pas mal buggé
et même il ya plein de trucs à optimiser
ne serait-ce qu'au niveau des succès
quand tu regardes deux heures d'un
stream bassett compte que 20 minutes
fort dirais que c'est pokémon gold c'est
avec l'epa pour les non ok généralement
dans la vie j'ai peur de me lancer dans
des gros projets parce que ça me sort de
ma zone de confort et j'ai peur de
sortir de ma zone de confort un peu
comme tout le monde mais là je me suis
dit ça vaut le coup
il ya plein de potes dans le truc il
faut tous confiance j'ai refait tous
confiance il ya aucune raison pour sa
foi merci je vous ai passé remercier
pendant le prime parce qu'on était
vraiment sous pression dans le truc et
tout puisque ça fait du bien de aller on
a fait la première émission
maintenant le truc est lancé et moi je
vais au japon et oui je suis explosé
j'ai plus que jamais besoin de vacances
et je vais partir cette année au japon
avec mon frère et avec mon père entre
couilles entre eux au char quand j'étais
à l'eau japon à la dernière je me suis
dit il faut que j'amène mon père et mon
frère ici ils vont absolument adoré ça
valait détendre ça va leur faire du bien
et cette année du coup je leur offre ce
voyage parce qu'on a tous un peu besoin
de se ressourcer de vivre des trucs en
famille moi j'ai jamais été très
familier ouais j'ai quand je fais des
voyages les subissent et quand je vais
ma famille je le subis c'est alors que
là ça part d'une volonté générale de
partir en famille et s'amuser en famille
et créer des souvenirs trop cool et je
trouve ça important voilà pour le style
petit moment d'émotion ça vous a plu
moi oui je pars donc demain au japon
mais pas de panique je vous ai fait des
vidéos d'avant je vous en ai pas fait
énormément parce que si j'en fais trop
bas il y en a certaines elles vont plus
la mer va alors que là je trouve que
elles sont toutes un peu cool vous
verrez jouer la surprise
et ben voilà les amis je voulais juste
vous faire un petit message avant de
m'envoler au japon mais on se retrouve
très bientôt dans un blog la semaine
prochaine et puis je m'en vais je vais
faire de ce pas ma valise je cherche des
objets une valise pour faire un mime
georges fut ma valise mais ça c'est de
la merde c'est de la merde
à très bientôt